kids
two of ben's fox news colleagues
pierre zavchesky
and sasha kushinova
were killed in the attack
and brent renaud a reporter on
assignment with time magazine was killed
in
[Music]
i know that everyone in this room in
particular
feels these losses deeply
being a war correspondent
is vital work
they make sure that the world knows
what's really happening when armies move
in
and bombs start falling
it also takes incredible courage
they go into war zones when others
understandably are heading out as fast
as possible
so these are huge losses
of course
for families
for friends
but also for their colleagues their
profession
their readers and viewers
who understand world events because of
them
our experts are in the process of
documenting and evaluating potential war
crimes being committed in ukraine
beth van schack whom the senate finally
confirmed this week is our ambassador at
large for global criminal justice
will be leading that effort within the
state department
we'll make sure that our findings help
international efforts to investigate war
crimes and hold those responsible
accountable
i'd also mention that there are several
other nominations before the senate with
a direct bearing on our ability to
support ukraine including for assistant
secretary of state for population
refugees and migration
assistant secretary of state for
international security and
nonproliferation
and our coordinator for sanctions policy
so i urge the senate
these quickly so that they can get to
work as soon as possible
a few weeks ago
just days before russia's invasion began
i went to the united nations security
council to lay out what we believe was
about to happen
again today
we have a strong sense of what could do
next
we believe that moscow may be setting
the stage to use a chemical weapon and
then falsely blame ukraine to justify
escalating its attacks on the ukrainian
people
manufacturing events
and creating false narratives of
genocide to justify greater use of
military force is a tactic that russia
has used before including in georgia
we believe russia will bring its
mercenaries from
private military groups and foreign
countries to ukraine
president putin acknowledged as much
over the weekend when he authorized the
recruitment of additional forces from
the middle east and elsewhere
another indication that
his war effort is not going as he hoped
it would
they're also likely to systematically
kidnap local officials
and replace them with puppets
again
this has already begun
the mayor of muliple was grabbed off the
street several days ago
released yesterday in a prisoner
exchange
the mayor of another city in southern
ukraine was also kidnapped
he hasn't yet been let go
this is a terror tactic grab local
officials depose local governments
put proxies in their place
after devastating ukrainian cities
moscow may bring in officials from
russia
to serve as local government officials
and surge what they describe as economic
support
in an attempt to make the people
dependent on moscow for survival
again something that russia did in
georgia
president putin's invasion of ukraine is
not going to plan
the ukrainian people haven't welcomed
the russian military
they haven't submitted
on the contrary
they're fighting with extraordinary
courage to protect their homes their
families their country
russia has been hit by unprecedented
sanctions
and cut off from the global economy
its own economy is in free fall
hundreds of corporations have closed
operations
in a matter of weeks
president putin has destroyed 30 years
of opening to the world and economic
opportunity for the russian people
dozens of members of the kremlin's
corrupt power base have been sanctioned
several have lost their mega yachts and
villas
president putin has derided those
sanctions using recent public diatribes
to mock russians living abroad as too
dependent as he said on foie gras and
oysters
meanwhile
he sits in his mansions having
accumulated billions
taking wealth from the russian people
while they stand in long lines to access
cash and watch as stores close and the
ruble plummets in value
it's no wonder that brave russians
continue to protest the war
and be beaten and arrested for it
and russian journalists are resigning
from their jobs at state media outlets
because they can't stomach parroting the
kremlin's lives any longer
still
president putin is not relenting and in
fact may be growing more desperate
and so yesterday
president biden authorized uh announced
excuse me and i authorized another 800
million dollars in military aid to
ukraine
that brings our support for ukraine's
front-line defenders to more than 2
billion dollars during this
administration
uh one billion in the last week alone
we're grateful to have a determined and
generous partner in congress which this
week provided more than 13 billion
dollars in urgent support to ukraine
and will continue to work with lawmakers
to support ukraine and hold the kremlin
to account
as president biden described this new
security assistance package includes 800
anti-aircraft systems to stop attacking
planes and helicopters before they
destroy more of ukraine nine thousand
anti-armor systems to destroy tanks and
armored vehicles
seven thousand small arms including
machine guns and grenade launchers and
20 million rounds of ammunition
we're also helping ukraine acquire
longer range
anti-aircraft systems and munitions at
president zelansky's request
and i've been in almost daily contact
with foreign minister kulaiba
coordinating to respond swiftly to
ukraine's most urgent needs
our allies and partners continue to step
up with their own significant shipments
of security assistance
i've authorized more than a dozen
countries to provide u.s origin
equipment and dozens more around the
world have provided security assistance
of their own
i'd also note that in addition to
assistance from the department of
defense
we're sending support from other
agencies including 10 million worth of
armored vehicles from our own diplomatic
security service
and yesterday i announced another 186
million dollars in humanitarian
assistance to help the more than 3
million refugees who fled ukraine in the
past three weeks
the fastest growing refugee crisis in
europe since world war ii
as well as internally displaced people
still in ukraine
this brings our total humanitarian aid
since last month to 293 million dollars
and of the more than 13 billion dollars
for ukraine uh the congress is putting
forward more than four billion of that
will go to humanitarian assistance
ukraine's neighbors in europe are
generously uh welcoming supporting
refugees
the united states will do our part to
help those governments and the
humanitarian organizations on the ground
meet this tremendous need
the steps that we and our allies and
partners are taking are aimed at one
goal
to end the war
the support we're providing ukraine as
well as our financial and economic
measures against moscow will strengthen
ukraine's hand at the diplomatic table
and we commend ukraine for staying at
that table and continuing to pursue
diplomacy while the kremlin's brutal
aggression continues we'll support
ukraine's diplomatic efforts however we
can
we continue to call on all nations
especially those with direct influence
with russia
to use whatever leverage they have to
compel moscow to end this war of choice
we believe china in particular has a
responsibility to use its influence with
president putin and to defend the
international rules and principles that
it professes to support
instead
it appears that china is moving in the
opposite direction by refusing to
condemn this aggression while seeking to
portray itself as a neutral arbiter
and we're concerned that they're
considering directly assisting russia
with military equipment to use in
ukraine
president biden will be speaking to
president xi tomorrow and will make
clear that china will bear
responsibility for any actions it takes
to support russia's aggression
and we will not hesitate to impose costs
let me close by saying that president
zielenski's message to congress
and to the american people yesterday was
incredibly powerful
he's asked for more help which we are
providing and will continue to provide
and he said that the people of ukraine
want the same things for themselves
that we want for ourselves
democracy
independence
freedom
no one who's watched the events of the
past three weeks
could ever doubt the depth of ukraine's
commitment to these ideals
we'll continue to stand with ukraine as
it fights for its future
we'll continue to increase the costs on
russia until it ends this war of choice
and we'll continue to provide
life-saving aid to the ukrainian people
as they endure the brutal consequences
of russia's aggression
with that happy to take some questions
paul
so what do you think about uh the talks
between ukraine and russia are they
making any progress uh president
zielinski seems to suggest there are
things they are talking about
so we're in close contact as i said with
uh
ukraine's leaders including in my case
uh foreign minister uh koleba
we're in close contact with
other countries that have in one way or
another uh been engaging
on uh on diplomacy
and
to date
i have to say on the one hand
we commend
ukraine for
being at the table despite being under
bombardment every minute of the day
at the same time
i have not seen
any
meaningful efforts by russia to bring
this war that is perpetrating to a
conclusion through uh diplomacy
we support
ukraine's efforts to try to de-escalate
through diplomacy to reach a ceasefire
and of course the withdrawal of russian
forces
we appreciate the efforts of other
countries including
france germany
israel turkey and others
but again
from where i sit
diplomacy requires
both sides engaging in good faith
to de-escalate and
i don't see signs right now that putin
is prepared to stop
on the contrary if you listen to
just for example his most recent remarks
yesterday
that uh suggests that he is moving in
the opposite direction but never mind
the words what we're really focused on
is his actions and the actions that
we're seeing russia take every single
day
virtually every minute of every day uh
are in total contrast to any serious
diplomatic effort
to end the war so
um we're looking to see russia take
meaningful actions to to de-escalate to
stop the violence that is perpetrating
on ukraine uh and to engage in uh in
good faith talks uh we will support
any effort that ukraine makes to do that
uh we're certainly uh
doing everything we can to uh to back
them but also to make sure that they
have the strongest possible hand
if there are any uh real
uh negotiations and if diplomacy does
advance hence the support that we're
giving to uh to ukraine as well as the
pressure that we continue to put and
even increase uh on russia
um thank you secretary there is uh this
department is confirming that an
american has died in ukraine today so
i'm wondering if you can share any more
with us about the circumstances about
who that person is um and if there will
be specific consequences for russia
because an american died um and then
second earlier this week you said on cnn
that one way or another ukraine will be
there and at some point putin won't
but we're watching every day
ukrainians are getting killed their
cities are being demolished so how can
you be so confident to say something
like that and are you suggesting that
putin should be removed as the leader of
russia thank you
uh kylie first with regard to uh the
american citizen i can confirm that an
american citizen was killed i don't have
any more details uh for you than that uh
but i can confirm that
um
second
it is
i think not only clear to me
but clear to the world
that
an independent ukraine will be there
long after vladimir putin
and
it's also uh
clear that this could horrifically go on
for some time
but when all is said and done
uh an independent ukraine will be there
and at some point vladimir putin will
not the real question is how much death
and destruction
is going to occur in the meantime and
we're doing everything we can
to bring this war
perpetrated by russia
to the quickest possible end
that's where the support for ukraine
comes in that's where the pressure on
russia comes in that's where the uh work
the coordination that we're doing with
countries around the world
comes in
but i think
the world has seen this the world has
seen the absolute
determination of the ukrainian people
to hold on to their country to hold on
to their future to hold on to their
freedom and there is nothing that
vladimir putin can do to subjugate that
to his will
but uh as i said this could
go on for for some time and we're going
to continue to work to bring it to an
end as quickly as we can
mr secretary
what you called russia's terror tactics
is the state department considering
designating russia a state sponsor
excuse me of terrorism and then second
everything that you described um the
words that the president has used in
recent days
war criminal murderous dictator pure
thug
do you think that there can ever be norm
relations between the united states and
russia so long as vladimir putin is in
power
so
our focus first and foremost is on doing
everything we can to help bring this war
to a quick end to stop the suffering of
the ukrainian people that's the result
of russia's aggression uh on ukraine
that's our focus as we're doing that and
as i said earlier we're also looking
very carefully at uh what uh is what is
happening what is what is being done
and in particular looking at the the
question
of whether war crimes are being
committed uh and among other things the
intentional targeting of civilians would
would constitute a war crime you heard
president biden speak to this yesterday
you heard what i said
a few minutes ago
so
we are documenting
we welcome the efforts of
various groups institutions
organizations
that focus on this to bring all of the
evidence together uh to uh continue to
document things and then for there to be
accountability one way or the other in
terms of other um
designations
based on actions that uh that russia is
taking we uh we are and we will look uh
at everything
julia
on the second question i'm sorry i'm
sorry but
as long as putin is in power can there
be normal relations between russia and
the united states
uh
again our focus is on ending this this
war i don't want to speculate uh about
the future but there's going to have to
be
one way or another accountability for
this war of aggression
so on possible relationships between
ukraine and russia if russia agrees to
stop attacks and withdraw its forces
from ukraine are there any security
forms that will guarantee
that russia would not renew suppression
against ukraine it's if it's not
membership in nato for ukraine then what
and another question president biden
said that u.s will accept ukraine uh
ukrainian refugees with open arms and so
far there is no official visa or other
program for ukrainians who are fleeing
war or who want to come to the united
states or reunite with their families
is department of state working on some
special expedited program for ukrainian
refugees and if yes when it might be
launched
thank you
uh
first
on the diplomacy look i'm not going to
uh
speculate on
the substance of any negotiations where
that might go as i said
we fully and strongly support
whatever the government of ukraine the
democratically elected government of
ukraine
uh
does
we very much welcome
sentiments that we've heard
uh expressed um for trying to bring this
to a diplomatic end as quickly as
possible uh i think in the first
instance what ukraine uh needs is
de-escalation uh it needs russian forces
out of ukraine uh it needs uh to have
its basic freedom and an independence
return
but i leave it to
ukrainian uh partners to work on
advancing the diplomacy if that's if
they believe that can be productive we
will look at whatever we can do to
support that and if there are um
issues that wind up being negotiated
that uh require in some fashion are our
participation of course we will uh we'll
look at that and see where we can be
helpful we want to be able in the first
instance to do what we're doing which is
to support the government of ukraine the
ukrainian people
along with putting uh
pressure on uh on russia
if uh
diplomacy finally carries the day and
there are things that we can do to
support that diplomacy and to support
any uh any outcomes that restore
ukraine's uh independence
we will uh of course look at that
and i'm sure do that with regard to um
refugees a couple of things
first as i said uh
this is the largest refugee crisis in
europe since world war ii the numbers
are staggering
uh and of course
what gets lost sometimes behind these
numbers
are the real lives that uh that are at
stake and that are being changed
uh
maybe not forever but are being changed
in profound ways
uh i saw some of that firsthand when i
was on the uh the border between poland
and ukraine
with a number of you uh just a couple of
weeks ago uh talking to people who had
made
the journey across the border uh looking
for safety uh in the face of this
russian onslaught uh and in many cases
most cases women and children uh the men
staying behind to fight
um and we see the impact of course in
ukraine we see the impact on neighboring
countries uh poland moldova romania
others
that are taking in
very large numbers of refugees the
generosity i think is is extraordinary
but the numbers are going
the
challenge is growing i was on a call a
video conference this morning with our
g7 partners
and this is one of the things that we
talked about uh having a coordinated
approach to dealing
with
and helping refugees coming over
the united states is already and will
remain the largest uh provider of
humanitarian assistance to ukraine part
of the package that um is in the
supplemental um
includes about four billion dollars in
humanitarian assistance
and that will go both directly to
ukraine it will also go to neighboring
countries and others and ukrainians
outside of ukraine to support them
second we are
working closely with unhcr
to see how we can support uh this effort
finally we're looking at things uh that
we can do ourselves and do directly for
example looking at steps we may be able
to take on family reunification uh and
uh and and other things that we can do
uh to be supported and to really take
part in this effort last thing i'll say
is this
what and of course
there is the
refugee referral process
um but that that takes time
but if uh if uh
people apply
for refugee status and seek to come to
the united states of course we will take
referrals but we're looking at steps
that we can take
in the near term
uh last thing is this i think what we're
seeing at least initially is that so
many people coming out of ukraine
understandably want to stay close to
home
they hope
we hope
that they'll be able to return home as
soon as possible they also want to stay
close to home because as i said in many
cases it's women and children who have
left behind
spouses husbands fathers brothers
and uh they want to be reunited as
quickly as possible so they want to stay
as close as possible but
as this and if this goes on as the
numbers increase as the burden
uh increases for european partners uh we
will certainly do everything we can to
help so i i suspect we'll have more to
say on this in the coming in the coming
days it's something we're very focused
on right now time for one final quick
question
mr secretary you've outlined um the
count of a litany of horrific
attacks on civilians
you said you agree with the president's
comment that
their warfare as the u.n ambassador said
last week
i know there has to be an investigation
but where will the accountability be
what should happen to
black if he is found guilty since he is
the state
what should happen to this
tell the world so andrea a few things um
first
we're all seeing
what uh and and you're showing
powerfully on uh on television
these devastating images coming out of
ukraine and we are seeing the
destruction
of uh so much of the country
uh by uh by russian bombs and uh
artillery we're seeing civilian sites
being devastated we're seeing
people being being killed
hundreds thousands of people civilians
and yes as i said again as the president
said yesterday um
in his opinion
uh war crimes are being committed i
agree with that uh after all the
destruction that we've seen it's really
hard to conclude otherwise but
um what we're doing is this and i'll
come to your question
we are in the first instance supporting
the very important work that's being
done the evidentiary process
to bring the evidence together to
document what's happened uh to support
and to work with human rights activists
with civil society uh with independent
media as well as with the uh appropriate
organizations and institutions that uh
look into this so we need to go through
this process of
compiling the evidence collecting the
evidence
understanding the evidence we'll share
that
and our allies and partners i'm sure
we'll do the same with
all of the investigations that are
ongoing to support accountability using
every tool that we have available i'm
not going to get ahead of uh
first of all what the outcome will be or
what the consequences will be but i can
say
uh with uh conviction that there will be
accountability for any war crimes that
are determined to have occurred
he does it repeatedly he's a repeat
offender
you know
andrea when um
when we said before russia's aggression
that there would be massive consequences
for that aggression
uh including
unprecedented sanctions on russia i know
some people had their doubts i think we
demonstrated that we've been good to our
word
uh when we said that there would be
sustained powerful support for ukraine
and its efforts to defend itself
uh we've demonstrated that we're good to
our word so when i tell you that there
will be accountability and consequences
uh for any war crimes that have been
committed um
i hope you'll take me my word but
actions always speak louder than words
thank you very much thank you
thanks
you